[Music]
we've been reporting on the more than
trillion dollar infrastructure bill
signed by president biden the president
told the tribal nations summit at the
white house just yesterday that 13
billion dollars with a b from that bill
would go to native american communities
including measures to fight climate
change one tribe desperately in need of
that help lives on washington state's
olympic peninsula their only village
next to the pacific ocean was inundated
by historic flooding yesterday ben tracy
recently visited that area and learned
how climate change is forcing residents
to make some heartbreaking choices
we've had these lands it's home to us
they built this wall and penn charles
has lived on the same street for her
entire life so this piece of land has
been in your family for a while yes two
generations it's where our family grew
up all along the roads here but just
across the way she has an increasingly
unfriendly neighbor
the pacific ocean rising because of
climate change
on monday the town experienced some of
its worst flooding ever swamping the
main street and forcing ann to evacuate
her home flooding like this is now
becoming all too common how concerned
are you about what might happen to this
village to your home
i'm pretty concerned that water when it
rises
you know it's just right over there you
know it's scary i see it anne is a
member of the quillude nation in la push
washington home to about 400 people the
tribe once called vast swaths of the
olympic peninsula home but in 1855 it
was stripped of most of its land decades
later president grover cleveland issued
an executive order confining the
quillute to just over one square mile of
land right up against the ocean most of
it prone to flooding
and now climate change is forcing the
quillute to move again that's the
toughest thing you know we don't want to
give up our land
at the tribal school down the street and
volunteers in the craft class students
here are already used to dealing with
the threat of a tsunami caused by an
earthquake
they regularly practice evacuating and
fleeing to higher ground on their school
buses
now the tribe is building an entirely
new school on top of the hill far away
from those rising ocean waters and while
it will be bigger and better than the
current school
some students can't imagine not seeing
the very water now forcing them to flee
it's sad then it's going to be really
different this is where a lot of us grew
up it means a lot to us
native tribes from alaska to the
southwest to florida are facing severe
climate impacts in large part because
they were relocated onto some of the
country's least desirable land the
infrastructure bill just signed by
president biden includes 216 million
dollars for climate resilience and
adaptation for tribal nations including
some funds for relocation our main focus
is definitely the kids and the elders
tony foster is a member of the tribal
council while government grants are
paying for most of the new school
construction he isn't sure if they will
get funding for the rest of the tribe to
move and build new homes on land near
the school
so it's not as simple as saying it's
time to move to higher ground no it's
really difficult for all of us to say we
have to leave
our home because of the climate i'll
pick up the kids later and penn charles
fears that day will come i'm not going
to move unless mother nature makes me
move but to honor her ancestors she says
she'll hold out as long as she can
you know we signed over so much land to
stay here it'd be tough to give up our
land down here it'd be like taking
taking our heartbeat and giving it a zap
and would be leaving our heart here
within our areas that we all grew up in
land this tribe never chose but a home
they may now have to leave behind
for cbs mornings ben tracy on the
olympic peninsula
just unbelievably beautiful landscape
there and if the projections are true
it's not the first story we're going to
do about people giving up coastal
property because of climate change very
personal isn't it yeah it sure is your
heartbeat and giving it a zap right
about that